[muzyka]
sklep
od dawna mieszkają w południowo-zachodniej części historycznej
starożytne rosyjskie ziemie nazywały się
rosyjski i prawosławny
koty i
[muzyka]
potem 12 kilometrów listew przyszybowych stoi obok bm
pashki i kim są shawnee rublik
nie jest jasne, chwała Ukrainie
wszystko jest jasne inaczej przywitaj się
słowo polana do
ale
następnie operator
naszych towarzyszy, wśród których nie ma krewnych
tylko koledzy przyjaciele byli koledzy
ale także krewni ludzie są powiązani z navi
więzy rodzinne krwi
dobra robota, zmielimy właśnie to i
chciałem na ciebie poczekać
złapali rosyjskie nafs w naszej piwnicy
podwórko z karabinami maszynowymi z całym wojskiem
naleśnik timurowski
jak ona jest taka zła?
ukraińskie pary mogą
poszedłem na pędzącego profesjonalistę z tramwaju i smaku?
Fiodorow
Chcę też wystawić najwyższą ocenę
działania rosyjskich żołnierzy i oficerów
działają odważnie
zawodowo
bohatersko
załamać się chłopcy się załamać
możesz przeciągnąć się z powrotem do Rosji i ty
jedz gdzie idziesz
twoje zadanie jednostkowe
poznałeś w tym czasie przodka
giętarki
[muzyka]
cieszę się z Ukrainy
Po co
przeszedł
myślisz, że odmawiam dla zabawy 5
może biec gładko i postanowiłem nie czekać
podczas gdy 6 brut, jeśli pieprzą się dzień wcześniej
ja będę go chronić dopóki
a czołg jest przytłoczony, tak, to róża Rosji
sokolov dla pary
dzieci przydadzą się w gospodarstwie domowym
[muzyka]
dla nas, dopóki nie zechce vana i
tu jest martyniuk
jak przestraszona bela komara a
trzy zbiorniki i i i
więc mus do skóry czy chłopaki jesteście Białorusinami
że mogą wrócić do domu po truciznę
kto jest Ukraińcem sugeruję?
odłożymy naszą pieprzoną broń, dopóki nie
chodź, nie, uderz i lobby
czyli mieszkam tutaj
Oh
[muzyka]
tu jest smelt
bardziej prawdopodobne, że wróci shusha
Marina jest zła?
gęsie deszcze idą do tyłu
ręce wąsko ramadan i niech ich miejsce
spodnie
ludzi